it was exciting to get I was thrilled to  get it just screw it was about this big  with a lot of script  a mother of course that's very you know  that helps to inform I'm sure and um  basically for me the idea is be there to  serve you know it was an honor to work  with her on the first film and on this  one with her scene would deny  um in the in the tribal council room  so like she just set the whole place on  fire with this with this take and I was  I was like I was just like this yeah you  know and then and then I again I forgot  to call cut and people just started  clapping you know what I mean and it was  everybody clapping like the grips you  know everybody was like now  so it was one of those mommies that  happens on a film and you realize oh  yeah that's just this is just for us  here you know like people watching  they're gonna feel it but like man we  were in the room when it happened  y'all was blown away by that